[Musique]
une arrivée du Qatar en pleine nuit
l'avion des lignes aériennes argentiques
qui proclame une équipe un pays un rêve
le porteur du rêve c'est Lionel Messi 35
ans désormais dieu du football mondial
[Musique]
accueilli au 102 muchachos l'hymne de
l'équipe depuis sa victoire sur le
Brésil en Copa América en dernier
[Musique]
on en a changé les paroles de nous
voulons être champion du monde
maintenant nous sommes champion du monde
il ne nous reste qu'à faire la fête
[Musique]
l'autobus impérial a conduit les joueurs
au centre d'entraînement tout proche de
la Fédération argentine de football pour
se reposer sous les acclamations de
milliers de supporters un cordon
policier les tenait à l'écart des
joueurs pendant leur repos sous l'oeil
vigilant de caoutchos au Tremblay du
pays Lionel Messi a publié ses photos de
sa courte nuit avec la coupe suivie du
Porot de maté indispensable à un
argentin
pour les supporteurs par contre pas
question d'interrompre la nuit blanche
il fallait assister à la lampe remontée
de l'autobus vers le centre de Buenos
Aires
[Applaudissements]
on estime que 4 millions de personnes se
sont rassemblées près de l'obélisque de
la place de la République par cette
chaude journée de congés avant les fêtes
et les grandes vacances de l'été
australe en attendant leur héros il aura
fallu tuer le temps se nourrir au
passage d'un petit chérubin mais en vain
parce que le convoi des champions du
monde n'avançait plus dans la foule
compacte parti vers midi il n'avait
trois heures plus tard parcouru qu'une
dizaine des 32 km qui les séparé de
l'avenue du 9 juillet ils ont dû
renoncer il a fédération de football
s'est excusée auprès du public de ne pas
avoir pu continuer en raison dit-elle de
l'explosion de joie populaire continuons
de célébrer en paix et de leur montrer
notre amour et admiration c'est donc en
hélicoptère que la sélection argentine a
survolé tout le parcours prévu
des champions du monde n'iront pas
semble-t-il comme c'était la coutume à
la présidence la Casa rossada rencontré
les dirigeants du pays Jean-Michel
passerait du Canada MONT